there's a lot of pressure to be
successful and to grow up making a lot
of money to live in this area
there is a lot of sadness and grief
coming from my classmates and I think
that was one of the factors that
inspired me to make this film
I started tenth attending board meetings
in January after the second suicide if I
can't even figure myself out
I want earth it my to expect anyone else
to
I think that when you see somebody who's
struggling it's important to talk with
them and be bold in your question asking
how they're doing and how you can help
if you are suffering from mental illness
or depression then it's really important
to just reach out to someone you can
trust
you